hey there and welcome to this pro flows
plus quick tip i am cameron and we've
been talking a lot about
camera shake in past quick tips so i
want to show you
how you actually apply a camera shake to
a camera
so you can see here we've got a very
basic scene we've got a point light up
here
creating some light and shadow we've got
the word shake
which is sitting on a floor like this
it's a checkerboard and we've got a fill
layer
for that floor we're going to go to
layer new
camera and we're just going to create
a camera we'll do 28 millimeter that's
fine and it is a
one node camera okay so i'm gonna show
you the difference between a one node
and the two node with
camera shake so we're gonna alter option
click for position
and we're going to add wiggle and we're
going to do something like
3 150
and we're going to play this back and
we'll see how it looks
and there you go there is the playback
and you can see that it's very
um it's intense it's right it's an
intense camera shake so we could
do something where maybe it's three but
it's
oh let's just say it's 50 instead of 150
and it's gonna be a much
um you know it's still three times per
second but at an amplitude of 50 versus
150 so it's much smoother
type of camera shake and we'll take a
look at how this looks here it goes it's
going to preview
and there it goes so it's still you know
somewhat frenzied but
you know it's an interesting kind of
kind of shake to it so now let's let's
try something totally different
let's add another camera and this will
be
a two node camera and we'll do 28
millimeter again
so we've got our two node which is our
position of our camera here and our
point of interest here
and we're going to hit p for position
we're going to set a
wiggle expression here and let's do
something like 1
150 and let's preview this
and what's interesting about this type
of camera shake is that our point of
interest is always going to stay here at
the center
but our camera is going to move around
that point of interest right so it's a
little bit different than what we'd see
with a onenote camera where there is no
point of interest but let's check this
out
so there's this movement right so it's
much uh it's
a lot smoother movement so i could even
actually crank this up to something like
300 and we could actually raise
our camera up so we're looking down
on the words here and let's preview this
and there's that camera shake so that
even looks uh better to me than the
first
two versions so you could play around
with these values you could add
a wiggle expression to the rotation x y
z you could add wiggle to point of
interest
you can really change it up even with
just you know changing these numbers out
and get totally interesting different
types of results
every single time hope you learned
something new if you enjoyed this video
i do
invite you to check out proflos plus
over at motionscience.tv